do we know what counts full first name
is Pauly none of us in this room knew it
for sure I haven't looked yet everyone I
guess so it's not just cow Calvin cuz
he's a junior so his dad your guess is
Calvin Calvin nuke LaLoosh Ripken the
third jr. Calvin Edwin Ripken jr. huh
Calvin let's bring in the Calvin Ripken
junior college you Calvin anybody
everybody I went to high school with
called me Calvin did your mom ever do
that when you got in trouble for sure um
that was a tone of voice Calvin let me
give you the full introduction here at
Cal is on the call of TBS's exclusive al
postseason coverage it'll be Toronto and
Cleveland tomorrow night at seven
Eastern with Ernie Johnson Ron darling
and Sam Ryan you guys called the AL
wild-card game and the Boston Cleveland
matchup let me let me start with
cleveland trying to sum up what
Cleveland is to a national audience how
would you sum that up in a sentence or
two I don't think you can do it in a
sentence and two they had the most
powerful starting rotation best pitching
in the league for most of the year they
lost that towards the end of the year so
you can start to describe them that good
power young pitching you know can win
when the experience manager like Terry
Francona but after they lost two of
their big arms down the stretch I think
we all sort of wrote them off and so
here's a team that still thinks they're
really good without two of their major
weapons and a manager that almost seems
like he's playing with house money he
says you know if I get a lead I'm gonna
do XY and Z and he's done exactly that
so how many sentences was that hi you're
okay you're okay um it's a hard story to
explain there under the radar but
they're a very good quality team I'm
very impressive you know offensively
they didn't they don't get the credit
but they scored the second most runs in
the American League
and Boston got all the credit and they
they got the big hits in that series and
they made the big place so they just
outplayed them and seemed like Boston
was getting going there towards the end
but they just ran out of time what
happened to the great starting pitching
in the postseason and I'm talking about
all of the postseason yeah you've got
guys who are barely going 5 innings now
yeah it seems like especially in the
early rounds where you know five-game
series can turn on one game and when
you're in that play in game as a
wild-card team it's a you're looking for
any signs and you're going to try to use
your whole team and so decisions are
going to be made much quicker but trying
to explain you know you know why Kershaw
hasn't had more success for David Price
you know two of the great pitchers
during the regular season in the
playoffs it's just hard to explain you
know the pressure is on usually the
scores are lower one run one run game
small ball a lot a lot of the minor
points of execution are important and so
I don't know it's just things are sped
up and it's a much more urgent the
manager sits over there he's thinking
about calling the bullpen you know if
any any sign happens in the first second
inning now no matter who's on the mound
Big Papi a first-ballot hall-of-famer I
believe try to think how do I don't do I
vote still no a big papi for sure he's
one of the game's greatest players one
of the greatest clutch performers and I
found myself rooting for him in that
broadcast position and you're not really
supposed to I'm sitting there watching
him and a big point in the game trying
to get a trying to get a hit and I'm
kind of thinking this will be the nice
ending to his story but what a story
it's been you know he's he's meant a
whole lot more to baseball I think than
just the numbers gigantic numbers he
push it puts up he's been a personality
and he's been really a wonderful player
for Boston and I got a chance to witness
it on that last Sunday
last game just to see how everybody felt
about them and then we were there of
course when they got eliminated the
other night and walking through there I
mean people had tears in her eyes he had
tears in his eyes what a wonderful fend
off he's Cal Ripken part of TBS's al
postseason coverage along with Ernie
Johnson and Ron darling and Samurai and
the reporter did you ever face son
darling Ron darling yeah I don't know if
I hit a home run once i think i think i
might have had decent numbers off it's
not something you go back and say he
owned me around him I like competing
against him sometimes he would make him
mad from the other side because he was
such a competitor but he's been he's
been wonderful in the broadcast booth he
knows everything about everything
there's not a subject you can talk about
he doesn't have some sort of recall he
studies really well and he's really
helped me a lot guiding and directing me
because you know he does it I would say
for a living yeah I do it a little bit
more as a hobby because I get the
playoffs and I get maybe a handful of
games during the end of the season but
him an Ernie are wonderful to work with
the pressure that you'll have with the
Dodgers in nationals you got a game five
you got Scherzer against hill can you
describe what that pressure is like when
it's the win and advance or lose and go
home yeah we were trying to in a couple
of production meetings people are asking
me you know how does it feel playing in
elimination games they look me up in a
they saw that I performed well and I
don't really remember it as elimination
games I remember the desperation of
diving in the first base when we lost to
the yankees and in 96 i made the last
out grounded to shortstop and i thought
that one minute I could dive the first
base and change the outcome of the
routine play but it didn't work out that
way but elimination games i think if you
really start to think about this is a
do-or-die game this is a do-or-die game
you start putting yourself in a spiral
downwards you know so you start thinking
about the end results and the
ramifications of such you really need to
wipe your
clean have confidence that that you play
this game and it's a similar game and
just go out and allow yourself to
perform and so it's all pressure is what
the pressure of the player puts on you
know the pressure is real that the
adrenaline is pumping the the atmosphere
is more exciting but somehow you got to
get past that and find a place inside
that says I played in a similar
situation than this before I'm just
going to go out and be me and if you can
do that those those guys seem to perform
pretty well so that pressure is what the
guys put on themselves I think we were
just talking about first album that we
bought our first concert we were talking
about Bob Dylan Bob Dylan got a Nobel
Peace Prize for Literature here this
morning nobel prize for literature first
album you bought you remember might have
been laid track all right I don't know I
was uh I was uh my influences were more
Motown so I think of I'll me see it
might have been an eight-track I think
it might have been Earth Wind and Fire
alright that's not a bad one to start
out with first concert you went out um I
wasn't a concert going go or I might not
i went to a concert so I got to the big
leagues either Billy Joel or heart all
right yeah Terry Kennedy when he was uh
we had a game in Kansas City and he had
tickets to say come along with me so I
went so hard but I didn't cut a lot of
concerts that's kind of sad uh no if you
look back on my life I was a nomadic
baseball kid my dad managed in the minor
leagues for the first fourteen years we
had a little bit different lifestyle we
went to where he was in a different
small community in the country and that
was our life so um you know I guess the
opportunities to go to those things
didn't happen until I was out loud can
you relate to Jim and John Harbaugh that
they grow up with a dad who was a
college coach and you know not at a
major program but you know they followed
along that that was that was what the
life was with the coach with your dad
being the same thing yeah I think I can
relate to
um to the importance of teaching and
developing and watching uh like I think
all the time especially as a parent when
you're dealing with your kids dad had a
lot of patience a lot of patience for
teaching and yet systems in which to
teach when to talk to people why not to
talk to people you know when the
emotions would calm down and I think
growing up in that environment so it's
very much like growing up with a teacher
you've seen this this game or the show
times before and you know how it's going
to get where it's going to get to it's
just a matter of you know using it there
so the kid or the player can can learn
from it so it gave me a good sense of
understanding of development and and
teaching so I was able to apply it a
little bit to my game but also to apply
it in helping others yeah we were
talking about this yesterday with a
football coach in Connecticut who was
dismissed because he was making a kid
run you're there with little league with
the cal ripken little league and just
how can you discipline nowadays well you
know the definition of discipline is
interesting to me because when people
say old school it almost refers to run
as a penalty you know or do calisthenics
as a penalty or do push-ups because you
were you did something wrong um I
witnessed my dad he's as old school as
anything he never believed in that sort
of penalty now I had a soccer coach that
every time things didn't go well we lost
we had to run the hill and and his
cadence when his whistle if he was EP
was ok and not too mad his cadence on as
whistle go beep beep which meant the
next person in line would go but if he
was mad it was just bpp and you'd be
running up the hill all the way down the
hill up the hill until he saw fit to
free to stop now looking back on that it
made me mad it also made me develop it
may be determined it made me many other
things as a result of that so I think in
some some ways there's a value to it but
I don't like the penalties of doing
something your association so
associating penalty disciplines all
right being on times all right
you know all the things that you need
responsibility to your teammates if
you're not acting right to them the
penalty is you're not playing the
penalty is you don't get to do what you
want to do so that's the greater penalty
yeah I agree playing time it's one thing
to find even a major leaguer I'll find
you know if I take away playing time now
it hurts you and hurts your team by the
way i'll leave you with this the best
average you had against the player with
at least 30 at-bats which pitcher would
you say you had the best success against
oh man I don't know I used to be
Saberhagen and swindell um now there's
about a nine there's ten guys ahead of
those swindle and Saberhagen 30 at-bats
that's like that's a pretty decent
sample size but it could be you know I
guess it's a Yankee it is yes and it's a
lefty would have never guessed who Ron
Guidry Ron Guidry I think I had a couple
of Homer's of him yeah you did pretty
well you hit two home runs off Guidry
yeah I was opposite field in New York
one time I remember that one you guys
don't forget anything you know that you
probably know what the damn pitch count
was I was a changeup to one and darlings
the one who went to Yale look at you cal
look at you oh I can remember those
things but other things about me alright
well just remember you're doing the
Toronto Cleveland series and it starts
tomorrow night it's seven eastern TV
then help you helped me with my my tie
and all that kind of studio years ago
yeah so now they got me as an experiment
what's not going to be experiment
because we going to do it but I'm down
next to the dugouts so I have two
stations set up with monitors and
headsets yeah and I'm performing with
the broadcast crew with Ronnie and Ernie
by headset but I'm in a different
location i think it's a it's really
interesting because you get to see the
game from there from that vantage point
you don't really get to see the game
from broadcast boots so any advice for
me to integrate what would you look for
from the sides i'm not i'm not a
sideline reporter i'm just giving you a
perspective from the sideline I would
you it like you did as a player what are
you noticing as a player whether you're
in the fielder at the plate you're going
to notice subtle subtle things that what
is said somebody's doing this it feels
like this if you can translate that as
what you did is a player to help you be
successful then do that as a broadcaster
because i watch i watch those things now
you look at the manager mouthing
something to the hitter you're looking
at you know defenses you're looking
about early things and the hard part
about doing that is trying to to
interject into the dead space of the
broadcast because you got those too when
you're three up in a booth you almost
can do hand signals and tap somebody and
there's a sort of a rhythm you get into
but when you're down there sometimes I
have to save those things for another
situation but that's how I see the game
though so I'm I'm not watching the
monitors uh nearly as much as i did up
in the booth yeah and i think that's the
way to go about it have fun tell Ernie
and Ron we set a low and we'll be
watching or night okay thanks buddy
let's Cal Ripken junior the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience